pas que c'est du cas par cas chacun par
selon ces raisons selon ce qu'il ressent
aussi
alors en revanche moi je peux m'appuyer
sur mon vécu je pense que beaucoup de
jeunes partent
parce qu'ils ont du mal à projeter leur
avenir ici ils vont aller le chercher
ailleurs il ya les guerres aussi dans le
monde notamment je pense à gaza où
beaucoup de jeunes il ya beaucoup de
souffle surtout dans les réseaux sociaux
il ya beaucoup d images de victimes etc
et chacun une sensibilité différente par
rapport à ça et je pense que beaucoup
partent dans l'idée d'aller aider ou
aller remédier à cette situation
ensuite je pense que c'est sur place que
ce fait l'ombre également puisqu'on
parle souvent de évidemment on parle de
d'extrémisme et puis du terrorisme etc
mais je pense pas que je pense pas qu'on
ait terroriste dès le départ je pense
qu'on le devient une fois on peut le
devenir en tout cas une fois sur place
parce qu'il y en a mais également parce
que des images de violence parce qu'il
ya un contexte il ya dit voilà il se
passe un certain nombre de choses
mais je pense que là les raisons
principales qui font qu'on part peuvent
parfois souvent partir d'une bonne
intention est que il ya ensuite
acheminement il ya une dérive elle se
fait une fois sur place c'est une
manière de se valoriser aussi parce
qu'on passe de pratiquement rien un
jeune de peut-être des zébrés ordinaire
dans un quartier où ailleurs et puis on
passe à ce qu'ils imaginent être le
meilleur des hommes le combattant le
martyre et c'est donc évidemment à
l'échelle de la valorisation ils se
disent eux se sentent valorisés et donc
il faudra expliquer qu' il ya d'autres
manières de se valoriser que la lutte
armée leur faire comprendre que la
violence n'est pas la solution contraire
que ça fait qu ajouter du désordre dans
une situation qui est déjà compliquée et
que l'on peut faire le bien autrement qu
à les tuer les autres faut pas être dans
le jugement tu penses que ça c'est très
important surtout pas dans le jugement
dans les jugements de valeur qu'il faut
simplement leur dire voilà leur
expliquer d'autres visions un jeune qui
est confronté des images de victimes de
violences a besoin aussi ce qui est
compréhensible d'avoir des réponses à
ces questions et je pense qu'une carence
à ce niveau là qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui se posent des questions qui
ont un ressenti particulier par rapport
à ça et c'est pas simplement la série ça
peut être aussi gaza où d'autres
d'autres terrains et évidemment ils ont
besoin d'avoir des réponses et le
problème c'est que la plupart estiment
ne pas avoir les réponses donc c'est
qu'il ya un problème au point de vue de
la prévention évidemment c'est toujours
mieux de prévenir que de guérir
moi c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai cette
démarche aujourd'hui que je parle aux
jeunes que je raconte mon vécu alors je
suis pas un donneur de leçon je suis pas
là pour leur expliquer ce que le bien et
le mal simplement je leur explique
la réalité à laquelle j'ai été
confrontée une fois que je suis pas une
fois je me suis retrouvé mois en
afghanistan mais je leur explique qu'on
peut idéaliser aussi
un pays on peut idéaliser
beaucoup de choses une cause aussi
évidemment la réalité est différente et
beaucoup plus compliqué beaucoup plus
dangereuse donc c'est ce que moi
j'essaie de leur expliquer à travers mon
parcours guantanamo et un est une
formidable fabrique de terrorisme
pourquoi parce qu'elle donne
l'argumentaire aux groupes les plus
extrémistes en disant bas vous voyez ce
qu'on fait aux musulmans et moi je suis
étonné justement qu'on a moi j'ai
beaucoup médité je mérite beaucoup pour
la fermeture du camp de guantanamo on a
tous vu ces images ces vidéos d'état
islamique qui décapite des journalistes
des humanitaires alors vie en les
habillant en tenue orange des détenus de
guantanamo
et je comprends pas pourquoi cette
prison est toujours ouverte et pourquoi
on appelle pas plus à fermer cette
prison c'est un peu la même chose c'est
un outil de recrutement comme ces vidéos
sont des outils de recrutement on est
beaucoup dans la criminalisation on
n'est pas assez dans l'explication n'est
pas assez dans la prévention n'est pas
assez dans le veut dire on traite les
choses que d'une manière qui peut être
même qui peut même être pour aller plus
loin qui peut même s'avérer
contre-productives parce que mettre les
gens en prison s'ils ont un sentiment
d'injustice ou qui sont à la base
radicaliser ça va le faire qu'augmenter
sentiment de radicalisation je pense à
ceux qui sont revenus
j'ai vu notamment danemark par exemple
qui est un soutien psychologique ceux
qui reviennent pour moi ça a été
nécessaire je pense que c'est une bonne
c'est une bonne idée
l'aide à la réinsertion c'est parce
qu'on peut revenir et puis décidé de
passer de vouloir passer à autre chose
c'est de reconstruire sa vie donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi aider les jeunes
à pouvoir reconstruire leur vie en tout
cas leur faire comprendre qu'il ya une
possibilité de se dé radicaliser et puis
de reconstruire quelque chose a ensuite
on est toujours dans la stigmatisation
dans la diabolisation
on est dans le point de non-retour vous
êtes plus pardonné ça y est vous êtes
devenu un terroriste on peut plus rien
faire deux roues vous de vous vous avez
basculé dans l'irrationnel alors que la
réalité est différente on peut à cause
de certaines circonstances c'est de
retrouver dans l'erreur mais on peut
revenir en arrière on peut reprendre sa
vie on peut la reconstruire la preuve
moi je suis là en train de parler avec
vous j'ai reconstruit ma vie la
prévention
comme je disais c'est mieux de prévenir
que guérir donc faut plutôt s'orienter
sur ça